[Music]
Thrones is really at the heart of it
about dysfunctional families hey
everybody happy holidays we got a whole
bunch of Game of Thrones to talk about
just right in time for the end of the
year they dumped a whole bunch of
information that gives us a really good
look for how the season is going to play
out based on which episodes which
directors are going to be doing if you
are finding me for the first time we're
doing Game of Thrones videos till season
8 gets here be sure to subscribe to get
everything there is a new round of the
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video to a lot of you been asking me
about the rumor mill there's a lot of
stuff floating around that might be fake
so I'm not going to address that I'm
just gonna be talking about the things
that the actual crew members have been
talking about and what the directors are
doing because the directors are picked
for very specific reasons on Game of
Thrones so we know when the big battles
are going to be happening we have an
idea for which episodes are gonna focus
on more shocking reveals and big twists
obviously we have an idea for what those
twists are going to be based on the
things that they set up at the end of
last season strangers I am this is all
due to us finding out which directors
are directing which episodes we had an
idea for earlier this year but it was
recently clarified so this is the actual
list and which director is doing which
episode David Nutter is doing episodes 1
2 & 4
Miguel Zapata neck is taking episodes 3
& 5 and then Dan and Dave are taking the
finale so we know now the David Nutter
is like mr. twist he's mr. red wedding
so he does shocking reveals big
character moments so episodes 1 & 2 will
probably be more big twists
Miguel suppose Knicks episodes 3 & 5
will probably be the big in then final
battle
so episode 3 is probably going to wind
up being the second Battle of Winterfell
just based on the trajectory of the
night king's army now it's totally
possible at the snail's pace that
they're marching that he could live
Vissarion down to King's Landing and
turn another army so he could start a
war on two fronts but it is based on the
structure of the season what it sounds
like is happening is his episode 5 will
be the final battle and then the finale
won't be so much a battle episode it'll
be them picking up the pieces the actors
have been doing interviews talking about
George RR Martin's suppose it
bittersweet ending that they're getting
ready to film Sophie Turner's talked a
little more specifically about Santa's
battles during the season Heather more
emotionally charged than their physical
making it seem like she's going to be
battling for Jon Snow's so so because we
know which episodes David Nutter is
directing we know which episodes will
focus more on the human drama and sort
of paying off the big moments that they
set up at the very beginning of this
series like bran stark meeting Jaime
Lannister again for the first time so
we'll dig into that in a second but
let's talk about the big battle episodes
three and five kid Harrington was doing
an interview because he had that
gunpowder series that premiered on HBO
this past week so people were asking him
about Game of Thrones so talking about
the big battle episodes that they're
filming he says I look back at battle of
the bastards now and understand what it
meant and what it was to do it but at
the time you're just getting on with a
job I will say I think I'm
understandably more affected by it than
I thought I would be this is actually a
clip from the commentary for that
episode where Miguel sapota neck is
talking about some of the big themes
because I feel like even though he's
known for doing the big battle episodes
he also does really great character work
during those two which is the real
reason why those episodes are some of
the best episodes of Game of Thrones
like people talk about winds of winter
being one of the best episodes of the
series battle of the bastards hardhome
those are all Miguel's supporting
episodes yeah this is the show isn't it
look CGI and I promise you is that this
is it this is real this shot the shots I
think and this is really KITT as well
which is and they stopped about six feet
from him at Full Tilt
it was bloody great and he did not blink
so because episodes 1 & 2 are David
Nutter it sounds like that's going to be
consumed with everybody making their way
to Winterfell who's not Cersei because
she's staying at King's Landing with a
small force in the golden company is
headed there but pretty much every other
main character on the show besides Euron
is headed towards Winterfell so the
first two episodes will be them meeting
up Jon Snow introducing his new
girlfriend Daenerys
to the rest of the
family the shocking reveal that he's a
Targaryen them dealing with that through
Episode two and then deciding what to do
as they prepare for the army of the Dead
to arrive so you can just imagine a
version of events where they show up and
they just have some fun
Daenerys meets everyone and it's a
little awkward Brandon Samwell wheel out
at the most awkward moment possible and
dropped the bomb the person you know is
Jon Snow is really Aegon Targaryen the
heir to the Iron Throne
because if there's anything that we can
count on from brand is that when he
drops information he always drops it at
the most awkward moment possible so you
just have to imagine everybody in the
Great Hall or everybody at a great feast
or some sort of private meeting where
you have all the main characters sitting
around a fire talking to each other
being really awkward but shifting gears
immediately he goes into three-eyed
raven mode and senses the night king is
coming
so episode two is them getting ready for
that then episode three is just a giant
battle for Winterfell you get your big
character deaths and then episode four
is them sort of regrouping and probably
going to Cersei saying hey this is
what's happened and trying to make a
deal with her Episode five sounds like
it will be the real final battle and it
will end up happening down at King's
Landing because we know there's a bunch
of siege weapons that are being set up
outside there King's Landing set so
King's Landing and Winterfell are
probably where the two big battles of
the season will be happening it makes
sense that if they're only gonna have
six episodes you're only gonna have time
for two crazy big battles those are the
two most important places on the TV show
like you started the first episode up at
Winterfell almost every single main
character was up there then you go
straight to King's Landing the whole
first season started out predicated on
the idea that it was all about Starks
versus Lannisters before we ever learned
about the threat of White Walkers so it
sounds like the big final battle will be
more of a human battle and that will be
Cersei getting her comeuppance they kill
off anybody else that they're planning
on killing off during that episode in
that episode 6 is the bittersweet ending
where they try to pick up the pieces and
move forward the dream of spring and I
do think that we're all expecting at
least one of the episode titles to be a
dream of spring if it's not the final
episode
but let me know in the comments knowing
what some of the big twists and reveals
are going to be now that you know the
list of directors and which episodes
they're doing when do you think those
big twists will happen and on top of
that we also learned some more about
what's going on with the Ironborn so I
am planning on doing an Ironborn video
but there's some other stuff that I'm
waiting on so that probably won't post
till this weekend let me know if there's
any bonus videos that you guys really
want me to do and I'll say
congratulations so the giveaway winner
from my last video the MK Palash please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details
announce a new winner when I post a new
game of thrones you can click here for
that Targaryen history video and you can
click here to learn all about the season
8 premiere date thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight